cette semaine je voudrais vous parler de
notre gros coup de coeur c'est le
festival télérama enfants vous
connaissez certainement le festival
télérama ça fait vingt ans que ça existe
on a fêté les 20 ans cette année
et là c'est la toute première édition du
festival cinéma télérama pour les
enfants et nous participons donc cette
année nous sommes très contents et il ya
plusieurs événements déjà il y à une
sélection de films de reprise des
meilleurs films delà de 2016 mais nous
avons aussi quelques quelques animations
et une hymne avant première je vais
commencer tout de suite par l'avant
première ce sera le film la jeune fille
et son aigle c est un documentaire qui
se passe en golly un peu comme le chien
jaune de mongolie et on suit l'histoire
d'une petite fille qui élève un aigle
pour faire un concours de chasse allègre
est dit comme ça je vous donne pas
forcément envie puisque ça mais c'est
quelque chose de formidable ce qui est
le plus impressionnant c'est de se dire
que c'est du réel
ce sera donc la jeune fille et son aigle
en avant première le vendredi 17 février
à 14 heures nous aurons aussi des
animations pour avec le film les
aventures de pâtes et mat c'est un
programme de courts métrages à partir de
3 ans il y aura une animation et il y
aura les marionnettes du film nous
aurons aussi une animation pour le film
ivan tsarévitch qui est le dernier film
de michel ocelot michel orso c'était le
papa de kirikou et de azur et asmar vous
retrouvez évidemment toutes ces infos
sur notre site internet cinemacon dias
hell.com ce qui est très important de
préciser c'est que comme c'est un
partenariat avec télérama et si vous
achetez le magazine télérama à
l'intérieur il y à une impasse qui vous
donne accès à tous ces séances il ya
tous les films du festival pour le tarif
de 3 euros 50 comme le festival pour les
et pour les adultes ce sera donc du 15
au 28 février et notamment au cinéma le
grenier à sel à trappes
à bientôt